en los suburbios estadounidenses ellas
serán quienes determinarán el resultado
de las elecciones las madres de familia
estas mujeres votaron por donald trump a
hace 4 años que van a hacer hoy veremos
a nivel que le da la espalda al
presidente y marie anderson que todavía
está dudando en las afueras de
filadelfia el hogar de nivel y sus dos
adolescentes
el colegio se hace con las tabletas ni
ni es madre divorciada y teleoperadora
para unas funerarias hace cuatro años
voto por donald trump
me resulta difícil hablar de ello de lo
que ha estado haciendo durante los
últimos cuatro años nunca imaginé ni por
un segundo que sería tan terrible en ese
momento nimble era fan del reality show
de donald trump
y me encantó su eslogan devolverle la
grandeza a eeuu y cuando lo vi en la
televisión con todas sus compañías pensé
para mí misma todo lo que toca se
convierte en oro
inves pensaba que una vez elegido trump
se suavizaría poniéndose el traje de
presidente pero con el paso de los meses
se decepcionó
es arrogante agresivo bueno como es
hombre de negocios no me importaba pero
ahora que es presidente me siento
avergonzada y apenada
la duda también surgió en los suburbios
de la parte alta de la ciudad de mini
tonka cerca de minneapolis marie
anderson es republicana de toda la vida
es divorciada madre de tres hijos y
tiene una peluquería y un spa le guarda
rencor a donald trump desde el hobby
cuando llegó la pandemia quería un
liderazgo fuerte esta es la mayor crisis
desde el 11 de septiembre
georg vivos en aquel entonces vi a
george bush trepando por las ruinas y
hablándonos desde el corazón supo cómo
unir al país y trump no puede hacer eso
se expresa
sin embargo marie anderson no renuncia a
su voto para el presidente está indecisa
y habla de ello con sus amigas
creo que ha hecho cosas buenas por la
economía el desempleo estaba en su punto
más bajo yobái de no las convence
joe biden no dice exactamente lo que
quiere decir su única agenda es decir
que el otro es horrible así que voten
por mí eso no es suficiente en realidad
es muy complicado
yo creo que sus espectadores deberían
compadecerse de nosotras es una
situación de arriba necesitamos
compasión win it can get para convencer
a estas mujeres de que se mantengan de
su lado el presidente lanzó una ofensiva
en florida una mujer
la familia trump se bajó de ese autobús
color rosa es la nuera de donald trump
lara
qué hacemos en florida
su mensaje sólo el presidente puede
garantizar la ley y el orden de las
madres del país después de la violencia
[Música]
si es muy aterrador ver el caos la
anarquía y el saqueo en nuestro país
donald trump fue el primero en decir a
todos los alcaldes de eeuu que les iba a
enviar a la guardia nacional estas
mujeres
volverán a nosotros
nivel dice que será un alivio votar por
byd en marie anderson está indecisa y
dice que decidirá su voto en el último
momento los dos candidatos tratan de
apelar a esas mujeres cuyo voto será
decisivo este 3 de noviembre